figuring out what to watch on Netflix
can take about as long as actually
watching whatever movie you decide on
life doesn't need to be that hard
so we've collected a list of the best
movies you can watch on Netflix right
now
no aimless browsing required from
incredible underrated gems to timeless
favorites that you haven't thought about
in years we've rounded up some of the
best movies on Netflix right now Kubo
and the two strings from the studio
behind Coraline and ParaNorman Kubo in
the two strings marks yet another
visually stunning achievement and
stop-motion animation the story follows
Kubo a young street performer in feudal
Japan who uses his to string guitar to
make origami come to life little does he
know that he's the focal point of a
supernatural war raging unseen all
around
Kubo in the two strings is an epic
adventure that's billed as a kids movie
but probably holds even more magic for
the adults in the room the imitation
game helmed by passengers director
Morton Tilden the imitation game is an
oscar-winning look in the tumultuous
life of Alan Turing the mathematician
largely responsible for breaking the
Enigma code during World War two
Benedict Cumberbatch delivers an
incredible performances to rank turning
a potentially dry historical period
piece into an emotional journey charged
with high tension drama he's backed up
by an equally convincing Keira Knightley
who offsets Cumberbatch is cold
off-putting genius with genuine warmth
both were nominated for Oscars that year
and for good reason the imitation game
is definitely a movie everyone should
see at least once miss did you really
solve this puzzle yourself what makes
you think I couldn't solve the puzzle
myself the babadook the babadook focuses
on an exhausted widowed mother finding
it harder and harder to love her weird
kid who's just a bit mentally unstable
it's a horrifying premise even before
the monster arrives the movie itself is
pure horror
removed from the typical grab bag of
jump scares and loud jarring audio cues
you find in most horror movies but it's
also touching her
warming and impossibly human in its
emotions put simply the babadook is so
far removed from cliche that it'll
probably start a few new cliches of its
own you could see no word or it's in a
book you can't get raped papa toka old
boy gritty moving gut-wrenching and
beautiful
mm Three's old boy succeeded on two
levels one it breathed new life into the
hard boiled revenge genre 2 it brought
Korean films into the international
spotlight old boy tells the story of oh
dae-su a middle-aged drunk who is
kidnapped and locked in a room for 15
years when he's inexplicably released
one day oh dae-su embarks on an
emotional blood-soaked
journey of revenge against the man who
imprisoned him what follows is a violent
touching story of regrets and revenge
with one of the most impressive action
scenes ever puts a film beasts of no
nation
Netflix's first original feature film
beasts of no nation stars Idris Elba as
a ruthless commander and newcomer
Abraham otta
as a boy soldier named ague beasts of no
nation is powerful shockingly real and
heartbreaking in his portrayal of the
unspeakable horrors of war it's not an
easy film to watch the pace is
relentless the imagery is visceral but
it's also undeniably a movie worth your
time the fundamentals of caring
heartwarming poignant and injected with
more lewd jokes and profanity than a
Farrelly Brothers comedy the
fundamentals of caring is still an
incredibly human and real experience the
movie follows Paul Rudd as a newly
certified caregiver working with his
first patient the wisecracking teenage
shutteth after a rocky start
they sat out on a road trip to see a
series of roadside attractions and along
the way they both learn valuable lessons
about family and friendship without ever
getting really sappy the bad news is
she's
refusing to sing fireworks apparently
she's done that with the last four
make-a-wish kids Captain America Civil
War undeniably the biggest installment
in the MCU since the Avengers 2016's
Captain America Civil War is proof that
Marvel finally figured out how to nail a
sequel it's a tour de force of
high-stakes action mixed with character
driven drama and all the right dashes of
humor even beyond that the movie reckons
with the trebling idea that there are
consequences to all the mayhem and
destruction we love to watch on screen
yeah break I'm doing what has to be done
to stave off something worse the wailing
equal parts drama psychological horror
and supernatural thriller the wailing
never stops to take a breath once it
gets rolling in a quiet South Korean
village a mysterious disease leads to an
outbreak of violent behavior among the
residents when his daughter starts
showing symptoms bumbling police officer
digs deeper into the plague and stumbles
into a battle between good and evil that
threatens to tear the village to pieces
beautifully shot terrifying at times and
scientific proof that korean exorcisms
are way cooler than ours the whaling
should be on every horror fans watchlist
gangs of new york martin scorsese is a
master at capturing the world of
gangsters in any time period few films
showcase that gift better than gangs of
new york which sees the clash of street
gangs in 19th century new york city
reach gritty new heights
gangs of new york is one of the
directors many examples of near-perfect
storytelling with beautiful
cinematography sweeping narrative and
pitch perfect performances from every
actor involved this is not only one of
the best movies on Netflix one of the
best movies period when we got business
not because it follows no cliches no
disappointments must have been the
mantra of writer director David Robert
Mitchell when he set out the foot it
follows on the big screen the movie
follows a simple premise but sticks with
it the whole way and makes an effort to
only let the premium chills make it past
the cutting room floor the story follows
a young woman who finds she's been
saddled with a curse after sleeping with
her new boyfriend
something is coming for her something
slow but persistence the only way to
pass the curse on is to sleep with
someone else
it follows comes in strong with a strong
timeless aesthetic it keeps you guessing
until the end the hateful eight in the
aftermath of the Civil War eight people
get snowed in at a roadside pitstop and
as the title asserts none of them are
particularly savory characters there's a
lot of talking a lot of bloodshed and a
lot of Tarantino nests all around the
hateful eight might not be Tarantino's
best film but it's definitely one of his
most interesting with a haunting setup
that resembles a horror movie more than
the Western setting it takes place in
you've come back with anything else but
in guitar my pistol plays a tune Dahmer
goos depth March you got it
the Fellowship of the Ring even after 17
years the Fellowship of the Ring feels
like a blockbuster that could have been
made yesterday
the sweeping intro to Peter Jackson's
epic trilogy was overshadowed by its
sequels so it's easy to forget how
incredible the first one was the mines
of moria the Balrog gandalf escaping
from ice and guard on an eagle the movie
is packed to the brim with perfect
scenes heck the intro monologue alone is
usually enough to convince anyone to
watch the film it began with the forging
of the great rings three were given to
the elves immortal wisest and fairest of
all beings
the Godfather time and time again the
Godfather has been rated as one of the
best movies of all time the story needs
little introduction vito corleone played
by marlon brando is retiring as the head
of the infamous Corleone crime family
and as mantle of Mafia don gets passed
down to his reluctant son Michael played
by Al Pacino these characters may exist
in a violent world most of us have never
experienced but they feel as real
assured next-door neighbors a lot of
people toss around the word masterpiece
when they're talking about movies but
The Godfather is one of the few films
that truly deserves the honor Wind River
when a girl is found murdered on a
native-american reserve in Wyoming the
discovery launches a harrowing
investigation led by Corey Lambert an
expert tracker with his own dark past
it's tempting to say that Jeremy
Renner's performances Lambert is the
highlight of Wind River but the movie is
so deftly woven together that there's no
one standout from the gorgeous icy
landscape shots to the heart pounding
pace Wind River is just an all-around
incredible movie changeling Angelina
Jolie stars as Christine Collins a woman
whose son goes missing for five months
before the police find him and bring him
home happy ending right not quite
convinced that the boy returned to her
isn't her son
Collins fights back against the LAPD who
in turn respond by labeling her insane
Jolie's performance in changeling is
near flawless as a mother on the brink
of losing her sanity and director Clint
Eastwood is in top form from beginning
to end more than anything
changeling completely immerses you in
the world of 1920s America I'll be at a
more paranoid thrilling version of 1920s
America than you're likely to find in
any of the history books City of God
visually striking and punishingly brutal
City of God follows several children in
the slums of Rio de Janeiro Brazil as
they grow up surrounded by gang violence
as soon as they're old enough to hold a
gun they leave their childhood behind
and cross the divide in two executions
robberies and drugs director Fernando
Morales went on to helm the
oscar-winning the constant gardener just
a few years after City of God but this
is the film that made him
household name in Brazil the movie just
oozes style and it's absolutely worth a
watch thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]